Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so big news marvel
finally confirmed Doctor strange for Thor Ragnarok,
so we gotta talk about what's going on and
how it can help them out with the infinity
gems and Odin.
There is a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
So awesome news that they finally confirm
Doctor strange for Thor Ragnarok big team
up.
They said that he be very important to the
movie.
So based on the Doctor strange Post credit
scene, we can guess that at least will be
helping find Odin that's were like the beginning
of it so he was seen like somewhere floating
around the set, looking like a hobo when they
were filming this Post credit scene.
So for some reason Odin is stuck on earth
and seemingly does not know who he is.
So when Thor is talking to Doctor strange
about why he brought Loki to the earth to
find Odin, he just says family drama which
is a pretty good summation of their relationship.
Just a lot of drama.
So it sounds like Loki just made a deal with
Helaa to banish Odin to earth and somehow
separate him from his power or block his power
because the Odin force makes him one of the
most powerful beings in the universe, so it
sounds like the most effective way of doing
that is just confusing him and making him
forget that he's Odin he doesn't have his
powers, but was the of the movie explains
that because the Odin force is basically like
his life force is actually made of the life
force of Odin's two brothers that died fighting
Firelord Surtur.
So that's like when the Odin force became
a thing and he gets a little complicated,
but the movies usually find simple ways of
explaining that but it sounds like Thor Ragnarok
is going to be amazingly weird.
So even though the find an easy way to explain
things the not can a dumb it down or just
like completely wash over really cool, comic
book stuff, so I have complete faith, but
it sounds like what's happening is is a whole
bunch of stuff has transpired like all this
Odin Loki drama happened that led up to them
seeking out Doctor strange's help and then
their search for Odin starts somewhere early
in the film because the main action of Thor
Ragnarok is going to be Hela is incursion
and takeover of Asgard from her realm.
Hela, so she's busy deleting this Legion in
with the help of Karl urban's scourge is is
you can be really interesting new character
Karl Urban is not a small actor.
So we haven't talked a lot about him, but
once again are first trailer which will talk
about in a second will get a better idea of
how he's going to fit into the movie, but
he's basically a Lieut. of Helaas sound like
he might end up switching sides at the end
of the film remains to be seen because marble
has this new thing were the doing like really
morally great characters that are just like
completely evil or completely good, which
I think makes for really great storytelling
I'm expecting some surprises from Carl urban's
character but Cate Blanchett is actually been
photographed on set she is going to kick so
much ass as Helaa and she is so powerful there's
no way that the gonna be able to kill her
at the end of the film will be like a red
skull situation where either they banish her
to another realm because remember red skull
is still floating around in outer space somewhere
whether or not Marvel ever wants to bring
them back or I'm really hoping that Helaa
comes back around during infinity war and
becomes marbles version of death because she
rules over the as guardian playing of death
the place where people go if they don't go
to Walhalla so I'm hoping that the movie doesn't
change that from the comics because is basically
held for as guardian characters if it sounds
a little weird.
It just because as guardians exist on a different
plane of existence like they exist in our
universe.
The movie is it simplified that a little bit,
but technically they don't exist in outer
space with us like if you had a spaceship
you could just fly to Asgard.
That's why you have to use the rainbow bridge
to get there but because Loki is magic, it
sounds like there's some sort of enchantment
that was laid on Odin the block and from his
power.
That's where Doctor strange comes and just
taking advantage of the fact that he keeps
track of all magical beings that are on earth
are like people from other dimensions.
Basically like a giant shit list of anybody
that could potentially cause trouble and has
powers the second big reason why Doctor strange
is really important is because the absence
of Odin leaves this vacuum of knowledge.
So what is Doctor strange do what we see him
doing the movie he reads a lot of books he
learned about one of the infinity gems the
time gem.
So, what was Thor doing in like the funny
comic con trailer that they released where
he was hanging out with Daryl.
He was trying to figure out the infinity stones
and what was going on with Enos.
So even though Thor's a pretty smart guy there.
Just a gap in his knowledge when it comes
to infinity gems that Doctor strange can help
felt like he has a giant library goes back
eons so there's gotta be some more information
on the infinity gems in there somewhere, but
the way they been talking about the behind-the-scenes
stuff for Thor Ragnarok is makes it sound
like most of the film will just be Thor, but
being up with the whole kit and Loki eventually
and Doctor strange will just be a smaller
part of it.
Just a very very important part though, because
if they're going to unleash Ragnarok which
is basically an event and as guardian history
from the comics is talking about Jack Kirby's
Ragnarok not the Ragnarok Thor duplicate cyborg
from Civil War.
The monsters of Ragnarok are like wave more
than Thor and even Holt could handle by themselves.
So that's where Odin comes and you really
need the Odin force to fight all of these
monsters and if there was any doubt about
how epic that big battle is going to be it
sound like it's going to be the big climax
of the film.
They actually showed off as part of the comic
con real it image of the whole getting ready
to punch Firelord Surtur like this giant like
you know, filling the frame of fire being
with a tiny looking little hulk like that's
how big the size difference was.
So just think about the idea of Holcomb versus
Firelord Surtur there really just typing that
up that might not actually end up in the movie
they just want to let you know that like hey
all this shit is going to be going down organa
do all the weird things that we were afraid
to do in the first to Thor movies because
there was a rumor that they were actually
in a do Firelord Surtur during Thor the dark
world, but you do actually get a peek at his
realm.
When like the nine realm start to align all
the big portals in the dark elves in a try
and use the 1/3 the reality gem to alter reality
so yay for Firelord Surtur, but really just
the idea of like changing reality will come
back around during infinity war.
This is actually the scene where Odin explains
the infinity gems and how that reality gem
works to change reality REMICs that predate
the universe itself.
What lies within his to be one of nine rooms
are noted that the dome is the evidence for
phone not on the dock.
Doctor Elvis range absolute lunch have bone
of the total ninth don't boast comes to the
way the light of the story his mother told
him to assist Joseph in the demonic if they
did with the note of the toughest school the
ESA while the other REMICs often appeared
of stone ESA is fluid and of the change.
It changes meta-into document it seeks out
host bodies drawing strength from that life
I like soul to use the return the one, but
after tendencies of bloodshed my father full
finally tried ushering in the peace that lasted
thousands of years he killed see you get the
idea there couple really old really powerful
people around the marvel universe like the
collector one of the ancients of the universe
as well as Odin who is ancient in his own
way very powerful who know exactly what's
going on with the infinity gems and just somehow
aren't readily available or aren't on the
team with the heroes, so to speak.
So you have people like Doctor strange that
need to step in and fill that gap like oh
you heard about the man with the purple glove
in the floaty chair that's who.
This is this is what he's trying to do this
is what these gems are capable of, if you
were to wield even two of them at the same
time.
It would be catastrophic lest he wheeled them
all at the same time.
So the be fun to see how Doctor strange treats
the idea of Sandoz after he's dealt with Dormammu
in the time gem like he's probably riding
pretty high.
And even though he's not quite as much of
an ass as he was at the beginning of Doctor
strange like that Doctor Steven strange to
sorcerer supreme mellows him out, just a little
bit, but he still kind of high on himself.
The way the Tony Stark is high on himself.
So just expect a lot of humor in the tone
of what you saw in that Thor Post credit scene
during Doctor strange just a lot of really
dry wit in Thor just kind of nodding his head
in going along with it like oh yeah this is
like the least strange thing that I've heard
today.
Growing up in Asgard.
Like there a lot of tales of the talk about
the warriors three going off as having adventures
that we haven't really seen on screen so you
get the sense there's not a lot of stuff in
the nine realms that surprises Thor, but like
you heard during that Odin clipped a lot of
this history he got as children stories read
to him by Freda so there's probably a lot
that he doesn't totally believe like oh I
heard this big story about Firelord Surtur
this tale about father and his brothers banished
him to a different realm but like you tell
children stories about monsters under their
bed the Ragnarok monsters are the monsters
under Thor's bed and they are very, very real,
like the mid guard serpent trapped inside
the earth which is real disappointment they
decided not to do that, during Thor the dark
world.
So all that stuff is coming back for Thor
Ragnarok Fenris Wolf Firelord Surtur the mid
guard serpent and probably just like a whole
bunch of other horrors from the nine realms
in the tone of the guardians of the galaxy
monster that we saw in that trailer which
is James Gunn explains it is not the Shuma
Gorath and a lot of people were wondering
about that, because it had all those tentacles
is just in interdimensional being that the
guardians are hired to get rid of.
We'll talk more about that when I do another
guardians video but is not Schumer Gora that
will probably come back in the Doctor strange
sequel.
So once we get to some of these other Marvel
movies and some more.
Doctor strange cameos, we can talk more about
the Doctor strange sequel because they have
talked about doing Clea as well as Schumer
Gora, but that's so far off the just a little
early to start talking about it now for the
meantime Doctor strange will just be Thor's
Wikipedia while Odin has been sidelined what's
going to happen next is I have some new agents
of shield life model decoy footage that I'll
post that knew trailer video for that and
I'm expecting some new flash footage to drop
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to rewatch that funny Thor trailer
and you can click here to learn about all
the awesome stuff that's coming this year
so happy about.
2017, so let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight!